[Music]
[Music]
I want you to wear this tonight stripped
on my gown so I will let you wear it
tomorrow night
[Music]
and see
[Music]
[Music]
our wedding
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
said the doc favor again with huh I
didn't know you were there
I think you're on her mark I thought you
were avoiding your young don't get
married so quickly tomorrow we can Queen
invite you to attend the wedding it was
just a very special moment and memory
for me and also it felt like a true
wedding everybody was there the
challenge people in the more folk and
the Dark Fae there was a lot of people
invited to my wedding there's a lot of
people there
the wedding dress was so gorgeous that
flowers were on the train and I saw my
sleeves and that those were like
laser-cut feathers tons of fabric I mean
it was really long I couldn't walk I
couldn't go anywhere without anybody
holding it up for me
the dream come true like I am wearing
this this is the Sleeping Beauty dress
I'd never want to take it off at all if
the hair and the makeup and nose I had
pink in my hair as well that we put in a
little knot so she's a little punk I
guess that's been green you me I
remember walking down the aisle that
first time with Angelina so it was very
magical the only way to make a person
fly and is there to be multiple ways
we did it with a combination of
different things tuning forks and then
real practical you know flying with
cables the tuning for you know basically
two prongs they fit either side of your
body and you can press someone backwards
or forwards or side-to-side really you
can get a 360 degree movement but you're
clamped into it like you become a piece
of the machine itself and you're working
with the what I think of as puppet
masters because they're doing the up and
the down and it's been but your body is
dictating whether you turn left or right
and then they have to go with you and
sometimes you all go on a cue and
sometimes it goes terribly wrong when we
shot the battle scenes there were a lot
of singles a lot of individual flying
seeds but there were also a number of
occasions where they had upwards of four
people flying at once when you've got
the combination of actors all had
different characteristics you had to
remember that even though we were flying
them all in the same equipment it's for
us to take the material after it's done
and to try to choreograph the animation
of the wings to work with the body
performance that we have that was a
really important element I know for
Angelina and I know that she invested
they do an enormous amount of time
specifically to talk about the way that
her wings would perform but the final
scene of the movie is that a lot of ways
it echoes the final scene from the first
movie the difference being knows that
his novel lifts him flying on her own
smooth and fine with the next generation
of faith not only is the Maleficent
whirl that builds practically it's
augmented through visual effects you
really feel like you're in the world and
then the visual effects are enhancing
that
often times in the moviemaking
you'll make a patch of land imbalance of
20 feet by 20 feet and then you'll
create everything else with visual
effects
[Music]
she has her wings the entire time
they're all done with special effects so
if I was in a scene we would have to
always make room for the wings we needed
to make sure that we didn't have any of
their wings interpenetrating so if
somebody was flying they had to have 10
foot of space either side of them in
order to fit them into the frame we
quite often have to stagger them
so lickspittles laboratory is right down
in the basement of the castle I knew
that this lab had to feel as if I was
kind of somehow connected to it
everything that was put on that set
it's all there for a reason the main
sort of focus of lickspittles world is
his workbench the detail in the set was
exquisite lickspittle had to adapt to
the laboratory to suit him and so
therefore this contraption was created
that goes up to the height that he
requires and then also slides back and
forth I thought it was gonna be a bit of
movie magic but it's just a guy called
Terry who is off the set somewhere
winding a big handle nobody's allowed in
here except me if you look more closely
you start to notice jars around the room
and in those jars or fairies skeletons
affair isn't the missing of Eric's I
think the set really feels like an
extension of lickspittles character this
is his world his entire existence is in
this this one room
today there will be a wedding tool
kingdoms United at last godmother
why don't you like Philip he's human I'm
a human and I have never held that
against you welcome Wow who is that
it's all coming together No
well well
[Music]